[Música]
quien no ha tenido alguna vez un
resfriado todo el mundo verdad más de
uno normalmente y aquí adivino algo que
habéis dicho más de una vez
me lo has pegado tu verdad somos así
como muy de acusar al de al lado eso va
con nosotros bien obviamente encontrar
si esa persona ha sido la que nos ha
pegado un resfriado queda en una
anécdota pero qué pasa si son
infecciones graves ahí más nos vale
saber de dónde vienen por poner
soluciones así que con esa intención
surgió una nueva disciplina médica la
epidemiología
a que no sabéis quién fue el pionero en
esto de la epidemiología
jon snow
yo sé que suena el nombre porque en
algún momento se han hablado de
epidemiología segurísimo
obviamente no estoy hablando del
personaje de juego de tronos así que
borremos
esto fue en 1854
hubo dos epidemias de cólera en londres
y ese año empezó la tercera el doctor
jon snow decidió investigar que estaba
ocurriendo ya que tenía la sospecha de
que el causante de la enfermedad se
transmitía a través de agua contaminada
el resto de personal obviamente no
pensaba lo mismo así que decidió probar
su hipótesis para ello
decidió representar sobre un mapa cada
uno de los casos que habían ido
produciéndose murieron 500 personas en
10 días así que era necesario ponerse a
ello se dieron cuenta de que todas se
concentraban alrededor de una bomba de
agua
el doctor snow decidió pedir que la
manivela fuera inutilizada y no hubo más
casos
este pequeño ejemplo me sirve para que
veáis cuáles son los principales
elementos que necesitamos conocer cuando
estudiamos lo que llamamos un brote
epidémico en primer lugar necesitamos
conocer el microorganismo que ha
producido la enfermedad aquí fue vibrio
cholera en segundo lugar importantísimo
la fuente de infección la ponga de agua
esta es la real para no es cualquier
bomba
y luego necesitamos también conocer la
distribución el grado de distribución
geográfica de los casos y luego tanto el
número de casos como la cantidad de
personas que han muerto por culpa de la
infección y en este caso parece sencillo
sólo ha habido una fuente de infección y
además sabemos que el microorganismo no
se transmite persona a persona pero qué
pasa si necesitamos saber más si el mapa
no es suficiente
para ello
se han desarrollado nuevas técnicas que
son las de la epidemiología molecular
aquí ahora con apellido y todo y el
molecular viene de que estudiamos una
molécula en concreto la de la abm
para ello os voy a enseñar otro ejemplo
que os permita tener una idea de a qué
me estoy refiriendo y os tengo que
presentar otra bacteria en este caso la
legionela porque obviamente en nuestro
país el vibrio cholera o la enfermedad
de cólera no es un grave problema sin
embargo tenemos otro tipo de bacterias
que si de vez en cuando son habituales y
nos producen algún que otro problema
como puede ser la legionela
hubo un brote en alcoy en el año 2009
que les tocó investigar a mi grupo y que
era fue algo bastante extraño resultó
que a una serie de personas de un
vecindario de alcoy que enfermaron por
culpa de la legionela
con una neumonía
lo que utilizarán las técnicas
moleculares será estudiar pequeños
fragmentos de adn que permitirán
distinguir la variante de legionela de
los pacientes de la de las fuentes de
infección habituales como pueden ser
muchas las personas
decidieron aplicar esas técnicas y se
dieron cuenta de que la genética decía
que no era la misma que la que solían
encontrar en estos sitios
tuvieron que seguir investigando porque
claro había que encontrar la fuente de
infección así que sospecharon de una
máquina que había estado trabajando por
la zona una fresadora esta máquina lo
que hace es arañar el asfalto y en el
proceso utiliza agua buscaron legionela
en los tanques de agua de esta fresadora
se dieron cuenta de que no sólo estaba
sino que la genética confirmaba que era
exactamente la misma que la de los
pacientes
y que resultó que la bomba de agua no
tenía los tanques clorados y las
temperaturas veraniegas pues ya se sabe
y multiplique se multiplicó en la
legionela cuando trabajo en el
vecindario disperso por medio de
aspersores aspersores de agua el al
general ponen por el entorno
pero ahora hemos visto que utilizar un
mapa y recurrir a la genética con
pequeños fragmentos sólo un pequeño
porcentaje del adn puede ser útil pero
qué pasa si esto no es suficiente
pues en ese sentido hay una sub
disciplina de la epidemiología molecular
que es la epidemiología genómica yo
prometo que no hay muchos más palabras
la genómica al final es una variante de
la molecular porque realmente seguimos
estudiando el adn lo que pasa es que lo
estudiamos al completo todo el genoma y
que es lo que hacemos cogemos la
bacteria extraemos su adn lo rompemos en
millones y millones de trozos que serán
leídos por los aparatos que veis aquí
que son los secuenciadores al final los
secuenciadores traducen esto a letras
que pasarán a nuestro ordenador pero
esto es un gran puzle nosotros
necesitamos reconstruir de nuevo y el
genoma
obviamente esto no es algo sencillo
imaginaos un puzzle de 2 x 2 km en
pequeñas piezas de 10 x 10 centímetros
complicado millones y millones de piezas
muchas de ellas repetidas necesitaremos
herramientas bioinformáticas pero no me
voy a descender ahí es demasiado técnico
os voy a enseñar un ejemplo de cómo esto
puede aplicarse y puede ser determinante
pero para eso os tengo que introducir a
mi compañera de aventuras los últimos
años que es la pseudomonas aeruginosa
esta bacteria tiene una particularidad
respecto a las otras dos que sí que se
puede transmitir persona a persona así
que puede ser más difícil no sólo eso
sino que en microbiología le llamamos un
patógeno oportunista quiere decir que
mientras estamos sanos ella está ahí
nosotros aquí no ningún problema pero
como estemos enfermos y hay una bajada
de defensas la podemos liar mucho y
además produce infecciones muy variadas
desde infecciones urinarias hasta
neumonías
no sólo eso sino que suele acumular
bastantes resistencias antibióticos esto
quiere decir que puede ser muy
complicada de tratar y además es una
frecuente visitante dentro de los
hospitales
así que imaginaos lo necesario que es
que la controlemos pues bien he escogido
un caso sencillo que se publicó el año
pasado en un hospital de londres uno de
londres de reino unido vamos pongamos
reino unido no vamos a liarla y no
porque esto no se haga aquí quiero
aclarar esto lo hacemos aquí pero he
preferido irme fuera y escoger algo que
sea perfectamente ilustrativo y más
sencillo en este caso fueron cuatro
pacientes que tenían infección por eeuu
he moza y habían pasado por la uci no
habían coincidido en el tiempo tan solo
pasaron por ahí a lo largo de cinco
meses
nosotros cuando estudiamos un brote lo
que nos llama la atención es que haya un
alto número de casos en un breve periodo
de tiempo y en un sitio en concreto os
podéis imaginar que cuatro casos en
cinco meses no es especialmente
llamativo sin embargo los especialistas
se dieron cuenta de que estas bacterias
tenían una resistencia muy concreta a un
antibiótico que les preocupaba
especialmente y que no era habitual así
que decidieron investigar
también se acordaron de que habían sido
previsores y había dos pacientes con
unas infecciones por eeuu giros muy
parecidas del año anterior así que
decidieron sumarlas al estudio
por si acaso se tratara de un brote que
no se podía asegurar buscaron por las
diferentes áreas del hospital a ver si
encontraban elogiosas y encontraron
erokhin osas en seis sitios desde una
máquina de hielo la entrada a la uci el
sumidero de un lavabo y tres camas de la
uci
cuando decidieron aplicar técnicas
moleculares básicas como algo parecido a
lo de alcoy un poco más básico incluso
que utilizas o utiliza sólo un pequeño
porcentaje del adn se dieron cuenta que
sólo podían agrupar a dos de los
pacientes con la iru he nos ha de una de
las camas vale hasta ahí muy bien pero y
qué pasa con el resto
cuando miraron en todo el genoma vieron
el cuadro completo
al final lo que tenían eran tres
luminosas diferentes agrupadas en dos en
grupos de dos pacientes y cada una podía
venir de un sitio distinto ya os digo
que emergen o sea es algo más complicado
porque la podemos encontrar en muchos
sitios incluso en nosotros mismos así
que confirmar que es el foco de
infección es algo más complicado pero ya
vemos que tenemos tres y luminosas
distintas por lo tanto estamos hablando
de tres brotes diferentes no sólo eso
sino que además los pacientes del año
anterior tienen las mismas elogiosas que
los de este año
eso tanto tiempo vista sería casi
imposible de ver si no lo sospechábamos
y menos sin aplicar la genómica
así que en un mundo en el que cada vez
más nos acercamos a no tener
antibióticos la prevención primero
utilizando la vacunación y después
aplicando herramientas de epidemiología
genómica pueden marcar la diferencia así
que yo lo dejo aquí pero os aviso de una
cosa nosotros si podríamos saber si sois
los culpables del resfriado del de al
lado muchas veces
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero no